[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'artothèque
de la Réunion cette belle villa créole
construite au milieu du 19e siècle est à
présent un lieu de l'art contemporain et
un centre d'information de formation de
rencontres et d'échanges entre l'artiste
et son public l'artèque invite à la
découverte de sa collection de plus de
2000 oeuvres et ouvrages sur l'art par
le biais du prix d'oeuvre d'art ce
dispositif du département est proposé
aux particuliers associations écoles
entreprises et collectivités
[Musique]
comme son nom l'indique le prix d'oeuvre
d'art permet par le biais d'un
abonnement annuel d'emprunter chez vous
l’œuvre d'un artiste déjà confirmé ou
d'un talent naissant allons à la
rencontre de Monsieur Baumel grand
admirateur d'art qui pour le plaisir des
yeux et des sens empreinte des œuvres à
l'artothèque pour les exposer dans son
salon
bonjour monsieur Baumel bonjour
Alexandre alors dites-nous quel type
d'oeuvre d'art empruntez-vous et où les
exposez-vous alors je vais en prendre
des oeuvres d'art contemporaine
sérigraphie et je les expose chez moi
principalement dans salon où j'ai un
espace dédié à ça à la prochaine étoile
pourquoi emprunter des œuvres d'art
plutôt que de les acheter alors l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre on peut acheter
des oeuvres d'art et on empruntait c'est
ce que je fais à leur totech l'intérêt
évident c'est que on a accès à un large
catalogue d'oeuvres donc on peut varier
la décoration découvrir des artistes
qu'on ne connaît pas et comment
avez-vous connu ce dispositif alors j'ai
fréquenté l'en-tête avant tout en tant
que lieu d'exposition parce que comme
vous savez c'est un c'est un
établissement qui est attenant au musée
les mondiaire donc tout naturellement je
suis venu voir des expositions ici merci
Monsieur Baumel merci Alexandre
est une galerie de prix d'oeuvre d'art
depuis 30 ans à l'image d'une
bibliothèque vous pouvez vous abonner
puis repartir chez vous avec une ou
plusieurs œuvres parmi les 2000 œuvres
proposées en fonction de votre
abonnement vous pouvez emprunter jusqu'à
12 œuvres par an pour les particuliers
30 œuvre par an pour les collectivités
et entreprises et jusqu'à 40 œuvre par
an pour les établissements scolaires et
associations
bonjour Frédéric bonjour Alexandre alors
dites-nous comment peut-on bénéficier de
ce dispositif que l'on appelle le prix
d'oeuvre d'art alors
du département de La Réunion propose un
abonnement pour le prix d'oeuvre d'art
on est une galerie de près d'oeuvre pour
se faire on peut s'abonner cet
abonnement donne droit à des œuvres
d'art des sculptures des peintures des
photographies les particuliers peuvent
emprunter jusqu'à 12 œuvres dans l'année
les entreprises et les établissements
scolaires 40 œuvres dans l'année pour
information on a aussi une petite
bibliothèque à l'étage et qui peut
bénéficier de cet abonnement alors
et d'une police d'assurance et quel est
le but du prix d'oeuvre d'art alors le
du pré-doeuvre d'art c'est de
sensibiliser en accessible démocratiser
mais c'est aussi mettre en lumière les
artistes locaux nationaux et
internationaux
l'abonnement à l'artothèque du
département de La Réunion donne accès
auprès des œuvres pour en bénéficier il
faut fournir un justificatif de domicile
une photocopie d'une pièce d'identité et
la photocopie de l'assurance habitation
pour les établissements scolaires et
associations un courrier du représentant
légal est à fournir également une carte
d'abonnés sera ensuite remise à
l'emprunteur
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur le prix d'oeuvre d'art n'hésitez pas
les coordonnées s'affichent en ce moment
même sur votre écran le département des
générations c'est déjà fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez-vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous allons
découvrir le disposer ses h la
prestation compensatrice du handicap
permet de compenser le handicap à
travers plusieurs types de prestations
nous le verrons
[Musique]